you're always going to get higher
Returns on investing in your own
education your own skill set compared to
any stock market a buddy of mine has a
daughter she was working out a bowling
alley minimum wage job he told her he's
like you know you can triple your income
if you just get a certification and
become a fotus it takes two days it's
500 bucks by taking $500 she could
invest in the S&P 500 and at 18 years
old maybe there' be a ton of compounding
but if she invests $500 in getting the
certification and then 2 days later she
triples her income probably a better
investment in buying the certification
than forever having a three times higher
Baseline for what she can make